allez allez allez
c'est le chat touche pas vous passez la
dernière aujourd'hui on est chez nous on
est bien sûr en direct
allez allez
merci d'être là bon ça va être la folie
je vous dis la vérité ça va être la
folie jusqu'à 21h15 et émission de fou
il y aura des surprises il y aura des
cadeaux il aura des invités il y aura
bien sûr tous les chroniqueurs qui
seront là ce sera la dernière ce soir et
on a déjà un invité de taille puisque
regardez notre DJ
snipers
avec tout le monde
et à DJ speep est avec nous merci on est
là on va arriver au studio on est parti
les chéris je vous cache pas que on a 50
mètres à faire en charge ça peut prendre
beaucoup de temps merci je voudrais en
profiter et profiter de ce petit tour ça
va les gérer
allez allez
pour vous remercier remercier le public
qui êtes chez vous vous le public qui
vient nous voir le public qui vient
nombreux sous voir tous les soirs merci
à vous d'être aussi nombreux à nous
regarder aussi nombreux à venir nous
voir aussi nombreux à nous aimer on vous
aime aussi également très très très fort
les Chéries et franchement on a qu'une
hâte c'est bien sûr faire une émission
de fou ce soir et vous retrouver l'année
prochaine en direct tous les soirs pour
la folie voilà les chéris bon on est sur
le chat tout va bien les chroniqueurs
sont là et je vais en profiter
d'ailleurs pour remercier tous les
chroniqueurs qui ont fait l'émission
avec moi alors il y a la plupart des
chroniqueurs qui sont là je te remercie
aussi toutes les équipes je remercie
encore tout à l'heure mais les équipes
qui ont fait un travail exceptionnel là
vous savez pas ce que c'est une émission
tous les jours en direct à préparer
c'est la folie et c'est vrai que ils ont
tous les jours la pression de faire bien
de faire au mieux pour vous donc merci à
eux et merci bien sûr à toutes les
équipes ici de C8 de la régie et bien
sûr tous les gens de C8 toutes les
personnes bien sûr susnommé qui nous
partage avec nous cette grande réussite
de cette année mais ça n'en parlera dans
un instant pour le moment ils sont là
ils sont là est-ce que vous
[Musique]
merci merci les enfants merci voilà qui
est pas qui est pas de drame c'est
faites attention aux enfants merci merci
bon les chéris voilà regarde comment ça
va mon chéri est-ce que tu es content
ouais je suis trop content trop cool on
va passer une bonne soirée c'est une
très belle soirée très belle émission et
l'année prochaine bien sûr tu seras avec
nous mon Hugo qui est vraiment devenu un
pote et only the beginning
vraiment vraiment mon chéri je suis très
heureux que vous rejoins l'équipe parce
que je suis vraiment géométate avec toi
autant en dehors de l'antenne qu'à
l'antenne moi je te fais un groupe et
vraiment tu peux compter sur moi merci
Monsieur oh mon bébé regardez là
tiens-toi bien là-bas ma chérie il va
falloir papa casser le fémur avec ses
conneries est-ce que tu es heureux
ok pendant 2 mois on va te manquer
pendant 2 mois
je pars avec une photo de toi de toute
façon
de moi merci ma chérie
merci
regardez regardez regardez la folie
regardez la folie c'est la folie ça va
aller chez lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va mon chéri ça va et toi ma belle je
suis très heureux très heureux il y a
une ambiance de ouf merci pour cette
somme avec plaisir rigoles ou quoi
[Musique]
tu es très très beau
très frais j'aime bien toi aussi tu es
beau j'aime bien tu vois un enfant de
moi
[Musique]
c'est mon monde c'est mon univers qui
est content
de la saison Soph
[Musique]
Ie cost la belle soficote merci merci
pour Kelly Kelly tu aimes bien Sophie
d'accord
c'est ma grande copine si on l'adore et
je peux vous dire que on comprend voilà
le succès qu'elle a tout comme Kelly
elles ont énormément de succès toutes
les deux comme Daniel d'ailleurs aussi
oui énormément de succès mais c'est vrai
que voilà on en reparlera je dirais rien
t'inquiète pas motus on parlera de quoi
ok d'accord j'inquiète pas
oui ça va bien
ah ça va mon chéri ça va bien on est là
pour la dernière que j'aime aussi voilà
et vraiment il a fait une année
exceptionnelle et moi j'adore mon Cyril
évidemment mais vraiment je suis très
content que tu sois là ma GG d'amour il
est magnifique et super chic
qu'on m'a donné hein je te dis la vérité
ça va tu as pas trop le blues
t'inquiète l'année prochaine on va être
là moi si on regarde
non non non
ça va aller chérie
merci à tous d'être là les amours merci
à Valérie Benaim aussi qui est là ma
chérie comment ça va ça va génial il
fait beau et que c'est magnifique en
blanc comme ça c'est le James Bond
tunisien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
juste avant qu'on prenne la guerre je
voudrais remercier Boris way d'être avec
nous c'est un monstre
et bien de sortir doucement
[Applaudissements]
tourné dans toute la France Boris c'est
un monstre il est mythique
merci Marie merci d'être là mon chéri
merci vraiment très très loin
[Applaudissements]
qui est avec nous c'est un monstre merci
Boris lala je suis très content de te
voir franchement tu nous fais un grand
grand honneur d'être avec nous pour
cette dernière
c'est le DJ du moment les gars voilà
c'est un monstre c'est un monstre il est
mythique et avec nous pour cette
dernière tu es à côté de toi DJ SPIP
est-ce que est-ce que tu veux jouer un
petit peu ou tu vas nous faire un petit
truc
mais nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allô allô c'est par complètement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
merci d'être là vous avez vu
pratiquement toutes les équipes toutes
les équipes quand il y a encore des
danseurs attendez je crois que
je veux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]